i'm carlos garcianson i'm a research
professor at the national university of
mexico
i've been working trying to understand
and control complex systems for more
than 20 years
and we use basically computer
simulations to do this
when you study a complex system like
urban traffic
or crowds you have hundreds or thousands
of components
and even if you have the equations to
describe them you basically need a
computer to solve them
to see how different types of
interactions will lead to different
global behaviors
we have lots of examples of
self-organizing systems in nature like
flocks of birds schools of fish herds of
cattle
crowds and we have
a certain understanding of how these
behave
in different conditions and this
understanding
can be useful when we study urban
mobility
be it with passengers in public
transportation systems
or with drivers in highways or in
streets that
depending on the individual behavior of
each person
the global pattern might be different
we're interested in
how can you regulate the global behavior
by adjusting
the interactions between drivers or
between
passengers in public transport
a characteristic feature of complex
systems is that the relevant
interactions between their components
and these interactions generate novel
information that is not present in
initial nor boundary conditions
and this limits predictability thus we
need
adaptability in order to complement this
lack of predictability and if we have
both
then we will be able to face complexity
much better than if we have
just one
we have proposed self financing
controllers for traffic lights and these
basically are independent intersections
that have sensors and they give
preference to the streets with the
highest demand and even when there's no
communication between the intersections
they can self-organize into so-called
green waves
because they basically form platoons and
these platoons when they are of a
certain size
they will be able to trigger green
lights even before they reach the
intersection so
cars don't have to stop unless there's
another plateau crossing the
intersection
and this adaptive mechanism
does not depend on the hour of the day
because nothing has to be programmed the
system
adapts itself and if for example there's
a
soccer match and then there's lots of
people coming out from a stadium
then the controllers will adapt without
human intervention
and of course this is much more
efficient than trying to predict the
traffic flow that we know
is not predictable
if you don't have a proper theory then
it's difficult to find solutions
but if you don't have solutions or if
you don't apply the theory
in the real world then it's difficult to
distinguish between competing theories
so uh science is pragmatic and we end up
using the theories that are more useful
in the real world so
in my work we try to combine both and we
have
theories that are based on successful
applications but also
propose solutions to real-world problems
based on theoretical advances